you got to take risks particularly when
you're in your 20s you want to take
those chances cuz you can afford to you
don't have as much financial burden on
yourself and you got to make decisions
of consequence that's why I don't like
people that become Consultants they
never make any decisions of consequence
that's why I never hire Consultants
after 2 years they're tainted they've
never done anything that makes a
difference to anybody they just make
recommendations all the time nothing
wrong with that career but they never
make a decision of Consequence the only
way you would Advance as you take risks
make decisions of consequences learn
from your mistakes you're going to make
many of them and just keep trucking on
down the road